dede sièges. Merci beaucoup.
- - Merci.
AvAvec nous, le panel politique.
BoBonsoir à vous trois.
- - Bonsoir (ensemble)
- - 50 circonscriptions à
susurveiller ses normes dans une
cacampagne électorale. 50, c'est
bebeaucoup. Je reviens à Monsier
Legagault. J'ai fait un détour r
lele sondage. Josée Legault,
cocomment vous avez compris cete
inintervention? Muscler ce matin
enen faveur d'un gouvernement
miminoritaire conservateur.
- - Lacquette : pour faire suite
auau sondage, à cause de cette
pepetite remontée récente des
lilibéraux, le fait que la coure
sosoit aussi serrée que la
peperformance d'Erin O'Toole des
dédébats hier soir était plutôt,
n'n'était pas tout à fait
spspectaculaire, la moindre qu'n
pupuisse dire. Monsieur Trudeaua
étété assez bon. Donc j'ai vu de
l'l'inquiétude. Se retrouver à n
momoment minoritaire libéral etl
a a décidé en son fort libéral e
s's'immiscer dans la campagne
féfédérale.
- - Ça m'a surpris cette sortie.
CÇa m'a surpris car il a répété
cece qu'il a dit il y a deux
sesemaines avec des mots plus
dudurs. Peut-être que François
LeLegault a été déçu que l'était
sasa sortie il y a deux semaines
nene soit pas aussi fracassant e
leleur expliquer alors il en a
rarajouté une couche aujourd'hu.
J'J'ai l'impression que la dépee
dede capital politique aujourd'i
FrFrançois Legault parce que je
n'n'ai pas comme ces gens qui
avavaient vu Erin O'Toole
s's'étaient amourachés de lui
sosoudainement. Il traîne des
cacasseroles depuis le début dea
cacampagne sur les armes à feu,
susur les changements climatiqu,
prprésentant avec les garderiesu
QuQuébec. Que François Legault e
plplace clairement dans son camp
mmême si c'est pas gouvernement
miminoritaire, il y a beaucoup e
cacapitale sympathie François
LeLegault, peut-être choisi d'en
dédépenser un peu je ne suis pas
cecertain qu'il y a de québécois
ququi ont écouté ça et qui ne se
sosoit pas dit: c'est un peu
ététrange, je n'ai pas le goût e
sosource que Monsieur François
LeLegault me dit. Peut-être les
prpressions que quelques québécs
àà rebrousse-poil que les
prprétentions de bloc ou libéra.
LeLes peut-être pour ça notes
auaujourd'hui François Legault.
SuSurtout le lendemain de débats
popour Erin O'Toole et être
orordinaire on lui fait une groe
flfleur.
- - Ces majeurs vont historique.
CeCe soir, il est débat en
ananglais. La position de Monsir
LeLegault est très claire. Très
feferme. Je ne sais pas si
MoMonsieur O'Toole être capablee
l'l'utiliser. Monsieur Legault t
ququand même le politique avec e
pepeu de crédibilité au Canada
acactuellement. Il peut prétende
paparler au nom de québécois. Sn
arargumentaire c'est le pouvoir
ququébécois. Juste Monsieur
O'O'Toole est celui qui défend e
mimieux pouvoir québécois. Ce qi
esest intéressant, au-delà de la
" " politique, voyant la forêt.
MoMonsieur O'Toole a clairement
enentendu la main au Québec.
MoMonsieur Legault prend la main
dede Monsieur O'Toole et on peut
sese demander, je vous laisse
pepenser le plaisir de réfléchi,
n'n'est pas une possibilité de
rereconstitution de l'axe ouest.
- - Vous rêvez au beau risque.
- - Ce n'est pas que j'en rêve
mamais j'ai pensé. Monsieur
O'O'Toole c'est humble, un
coconservateur bleu ce n'est pas
ététonnant qu'il fasse ça. Québc
veversus le reste du Canada. L'n
pepeut influer sur l'autre.
N'N'oublions pas que les modes e
ququébécois étaient vraiment
vovolatiles. On a vu que québécs
nene sont pas encore décidés. Ls
ququébécois doivent voter
mamassivement pour les
coconservateurs ont déjà voté
mamassivement par les démocrates
jeje ne sais pas si un élection
avavec du mouvement. Monsieur
O'O'Toole se mettait à progressr
unun peu, les facteurs Maxime
BeBernier qui peut lui nuire
bebeaucoup.
- - Voyez là un grand mouvement
cocomme il y a déjà eu à plusies
rereprises dans l'histoire.
- - Ce que je veux dire ce que
c'c'est maintenant la semaine
prprochaine on réalise que O'Toe
a a l'air parfait pour l'emport,
jeje ne suis pas de québécois qi
aiaime voter du bon bord. On va
bebeaucoup plus fort qu'on pense
etet je..
- - parlez-moi de garderies.
- - Je vais finir garderies,
gagarderies, Monsieur Legault
ababsout jusqu'à un certain. La
grgrosse faute de Monsieur O'Toe
enen ce qui a trait aux garderi.
MoMonsieur O'Toole à l'égard du
QuQuébec a réussi l'essentiel. e
n'n'est pas les conservateurs na
papas fini mes collègues, mais l
n'n'a pas suscité d'animosité.
- - Vous êtes plus arrêtés que s
chchefs.
- - José et Alec. Christian
ututilise absurde, la dit ce man
onon n'est pas très content de
susuite après le renaître Monsir
TrTrudeau. On a l'impression que
cece dit, je vais régler ça mais
enen même temps mais après
gagarderies c'est assez complex.
- - Il regrettait continuellemet
lele constructeur sous Monsieur
TrTrudeau très durement.
SoSous Monsieur O'Toole là je ss
d'd'accord avec Alex et moi ausi
jeje pense que même si énormémet
dede capital politique à dépens,
ilil ne dépensait une partie ce
mamatin. Justement, le parti
coconservateur d'Erin O'Toole ce
n'n'est pas le parti conservater
dede Brian Mulroney. C'est encoe
lele parti conservateur de Stepn
HaHarper. Et Stephen Harper en
202006 a fait aussi le coût de a
grgrande séduction au Québec,
l'l'ouverture la
dédécentralisation... mais pendt
leles 10 ans ou la la, c'était s
gegestes essentiellement
sysymboliques. N'a pas e eu de
susubstance et Monsieur Legault
didit recherchait une plus grane
auautonomie pour le Québec. Les
nanationalistes il se dit aussi
auautonomiste. Et qui dit
auautonomie dit élargissement ds
drdroits du Québec. On ne parle
papas seulement en dessous, argt
enen parle d'élargissement.
MoMonsieur O'Toole est à la tête
dede gouvernement qui est
papancanadien, qui a des intérês
ququi pensent encore beaucoup vs
l'l'Ouest canadien. Beaucoup des
intétérêts encore pour l'induste
pépétrolière etc. Une base
mimilitaires qui sont sceptique,
sosoit contre le droit des femms
àà l'avortement. Alors il choist
unun camp. Premièrement cela
coconstitue une référence de
prpremier ministre provincial en
popolitique des râles, il choist
unun camp qui ne plaît pas
nénécessairement ne rencontre ps
nénécessairement les autres
vavaleurs de beaucoup de
ququébécois. Les valeurs aussi
sosociales.
- - Les conservateurs ils ne
cocomprennent pas de Stephen
HaHarper envahissaient-moi les
cocompétences provinciales. Je
trtrouve que la pression de
FrFrançois Legault terme de
popouvoir québécois extrêmement
sosolide. Cela semble
inincontestable que les
coconservateurs d'Erin O'Toole
vovont moins attaquer les
lilibéraux.
- - Est-ce qu'on peut juste
rarappeler que gouvernements
lilibéraux fédéraux que Monsieur
BoBouchard a négociés des choses
inintéressantes sur le plan
coconstitutionnel dans derniers
momois, c'est ça qui est un peu
susurréaliste ce matin, entre
LeLegault et Justin Trudeau qui
ététait rendu à ce tu es à toi t
nénégocié intéressantes dont ele
sese de garde.
- - Sur le service de garde,
MoMonsieur Legault a réussi à
avavoir 6 milliards sans
cocondition. La répéter, il peut
dédépenser où il veut. Il peut n
prprendre même pour le troisième
lilien. Peut dépenser où il veut
lele 6 milliards. Hélas, un mois
apaprès... comment vous Prock
cocomprenez ça?
- - il y a 2 milliards pour le
hahaut de vitesse, de l'argent
popour les batteries, pour
l'l'aérospatiale. Dans le cas de
JuJustin Trudeau, de trouver que
soson ami n'a pas pris beaucoupe
tetemps avant de reverser sa
chchemise. Mais tant qu'on a dû
trtrouver ça un peu fort, mais i
vovous voulez avoir une idée du
fafait que les autres parties à
l'l'Assemblée nationale ont ausi
pepensé aujourd'hui François
LeLegault a fait une sortie un u
plplus spéciale, garder la
réréaction de Parti libéral de
QuQuébec solidaire. Tout de suie
unune opportunité de dire: nous
gagarderies, on veut le complét,
enen vue de place aux gens, les
fafamilles de nouvelles places.
AmAmbulatoire d'Ottawa. Legault
dadans le champ avec son appui à
ErErin O'Toole.
- - Assemblée nationale on prépe
l'l'élection dans un an et ça ne
papasse pas inaperçue.
- - Je à vous parler de ce momet
dede cette prise de bec de ce
momoment intense entre Monsieur
TrTrudeau et Monsieur Blanchet.n
vava écouter donc un extrait du
dédébat sur le Québec, ce qui
dédéfend le mieux la Monsieur
TrTrudeau s'est senti attaquer à
totort ou à raison il y a eu ce.
FRFRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
prpremier ministre du Québec
- - Moi, je suis nationaliste.
- - Mais s'il ne faut pas dire x
nanations autochtones quoi faire
ouou quoi penser, pourquoi dit-l
àà la nation québécoise
ququoi faire et quoi penser?
(r(rires)
- - Parce que je suis Québécois,
MoMonsieur Blanchet. Un fait que
vovous oubliez constamment.
- - Ça ne vous donne pas le drot
dede donner des leçons.
- - Mais non, vous ne m'accuserz
papas d'être... pas québécois
MoMonsieur Blanchet.
- - La démocratie québécoise
s's'exprime à l'Assemblée
nanationale du Québec
- - Et au gouvernement du Canada
auaussi.
- - et le premier ministre du
CaCanada qui ne me laisse pas
paparler. Il doit avoir peur de
ququelque chose.
- - Monsieur Blanchet, votre
coconclusion.
- - Va toujours à l'encontre de
lala volonté de l'Assemblée
nanationale du Québec en matière
dede langue et de parole.
- - Monsieur O'Toole, rapidement
2020 secondes.
- - Non, c'est la démocratie
ququébécoise.
- - Et d'ailleurs, je peux
vovous dire, Monsieur Blanchet,
quque vous m'attaquez de ne pas
êêtre québécois...
QuQuand je vous dis, Monsieur
BlBlanchet, que vous ne voulez s
l'l'ingérence du fédéral au
QuQuébec, puis ensuite vous prez
lele bilan du gouvernement
cocomme étant le vôtre, ce sont
dedes contradictions profondes.
MaMais non, vous ne m'accuserez
papas de ne pas être québécois,
MoMonsieur Blanchet!
- - Je pense que Monsieur Trudeu
a a bien fait de rappeler qu'il
esest québécois. Se rappeler que
leles plans québécois se sont
efeffondrés répondent Erin O'Toe
ququi éduquent deux langues
ququébécoises. Ce était fié de
nonommer autochtone Monsieur
BlBlanchet accroché au niveau
féfédéral à ce qu'on reconnaisse
ofofficiellement les langues
auautochtones. Je suis étonné qe
pepersonne n'ait noté ça. Sont e
fifier québécois mais ce qui
dédéfende le fédéral ça été Erin
O'O'Toole.
- - Je pense que Justin Trudeau
atattendait le moment pour dire
ququ'il était québécois aussi, l
y y a plusieurs courant au Québc
etet qu'il n'y a pas un seul pai
ququi parle pour l'ensemble du
QuQuébec. Parce que quand on
reregarde la fin de la terre de
JuJustin Trudeau,: ne maîtrisert
papas de ne pas être québécois.n
sesent que ça l'a piqué au vif
prprogrès, je pense que j'avaisà
tete rappeler qu'il est québéco.
MaMais peut-être allez un petit
pepeu loin. En même temps un sor
ilil n'y avait pas beaucoup
d'd'étincelles et klaxonnaient
reretenir l'attention et je peux
vovous dire que les troupes
libérales au Québec ont retenu
lala ferveur de son et ça aura
fafait plaisir. Il avait hâte de
popour la placer celle-là dans e
dédébat.
- - Son environnement, sa
gagarderie, il y a eu des momen.
JoJosé.
- - À mon âge avancé j'ai attenu
unun peu les coups de son père n
pepeu en moins baveux. L'un des
slslogans du camp du non était n
nonom est québécois. Cela aidera
pepeut-être important. La deuxie
chchose c'est l'agacement je pee
ququ'il commence à gagner pas
seseulement le parti libéral du
CaCanada mais des autres parties
lala Chambre des communes face a
YvYves-François Blanchet qui
cocontrairement à Duceppe s'arre
lele titre de défenseur unique t
susuprême et ultime du Québec,
nanation les intérêts du Québec.
C'C'est sûr que c'est un petit u
çaça je pense hier soir qui est
sosorti cette frustration.
- - Débat 21 heures ce soir. Les
AnAndrianov bambins des débats.
DeDerni en anglais mais on ne
paparle. Avec J. Le niveau des
sosondages, la course est très
seserrée. Quelques allaient
susurveiller ce soir?
- - Je vais surveiller une houle
bibien entendue parce que en
frfrançais tout le monde l'a
reremarqué, les traits robotiqu,
ilil est vraiment crypté. On va
vovoir s'il va réussir à être un
pepeu plus humain, c'est d'avoir
unun peu plus de passion il va
enenfin pouvoir expliquer son pn
unun petit peu mieux. Justin
TrTrudeau qui je pense, va lui
auaussi être particulièrement
énénergisé.
- - Alec.
- - Erin O'Toole a clairement le
plplus à perdre ce soir parce qe
çaça monte et elle est amenée. u
mimieux il distingue dans les
sosondages, sinon il régresse un
pepeu. Les libéraux sont remont.
CeCe qui fait qu'on est au coudà
cocoude dans les sondages
acactuellement. Doit absolument
avavoir un bon débat. Ça fait ue
sesemaine qu'il est sur la
dédéfensive des armes à feu, sot
gagarderie au Québec. Il peut
prprendre les sept derniers jous
etet les jeter à la poubelle.
C'C'est un ordre de campagne de0
jojours. Doit absolument
auaujourd'hui, ce soir paramètre
dédébats et Jagmeet Singh doit
êêtre un peu moins effacé, il
dodoit être capable d'expliquer
soson plan. De la compassion c't
bibien, de la empathie c'est bin
mamais c'est toujours parce quee
NPNPD offrira.
- - La SCI à intervenir souvent.
PePeut-être je l'ai i trop étei.
ChChristian.
- - Surveiller Monsieur O'Toole
popour votre capable de du cadeu
dede Monsieur Legault. Ce qui et
àà surveiller c'est l'Ontario,
ToToronto qui va être visé. Este
quque les libéraux vont être
cacapable de faire peur aux gens
ququi sont tentés de voter nos
dédémocrates. Ne pas voter
dédémocrate car il y a un risque
sésérieux de gouvernement
coconservateur. C'est clair quea
vava être crucial ce soir parce
quque ça peut, tout peut arrive.
- - Madame Paule hier, premier
momoment le grand public la
rerencontrait. Qu'est-ce qu'il
vovous vient à l'esprit?
- - c'était trop peu trop tard
d'd'une certaine manière. On ne
l'l'a pas vu au Québec du tout e
lala campagne. Elle est carnée
dadans ce comté, il y a eu
ququelques bonnes interventions
dodont justement sur les servics
dede garde. S'il y avait eu plus
dede femmes à la tête des parti,
pepeut-être... et d'ailleurs au
QuQuébec la vie de Pauline Maro.
JeJe pense qu'elle avait un très
bobon point. La venue au débat
enentre chacun n'avait rien à
gagagner de toute manière.
- - Je vais leur dire à un momet
dodonné car le NPD et elle était
totous d'accord sur tout hier. s
ététai